agent 89 joins us from the ATL right
here on the show how you doing Steve I'm
doing fine I want to just bounce off you
the topic du jour about Thursday Night
Football if you heard what Sean Payton
had to say and certainly drew Brees just
right put a put a finger right on it
about how dangerous it is for players to
play Thursday Night Football leading to
more injuries what what was it like for
you to get up for Thursday Night
Football game Steve well first when you
talk about Thursday night you later in
the season all those games seem to be
extremely important and then you have
the division rivals so yes they become
slobberknocker is there more but many
car crashes are bigger on faster just
because of the value of the game what's
at stake so you saw in that game man
dudes are getting escorted to that uh
that little blue tent um you know like
like they like they lost their ticket to
amusement park you know it just was a
lot going on you know it took concussion
protocol was at his finest and they were
spotting checking players and I think
they missed some players to Ty seem to
get up little woozy at times um so I
agree doing it later the season is
really hard that's why the NFL PA had
implemented with the league
understanding you minimize how much
contact these guys are playing because
it's wear and tear on your body I don't
care how old you are how young you you
are it's a lot of banging going on and
you got to monitor it but what did you
feel when you were playing that there
were some times that you were not ready
to play Thursday night because it came
too quickly
Steve no on Monday yes you're like man I
got a play on Thursday first of all as a
player you go man what does coach gonna
do today
you know heisting on act you know
especially based on the performance of
the team um so what you have to do is
you create a routine very early in your
career so your routine has always helped
to refresh you but
refreshed worn down when you accept that
Jersey I always told myself before I go
out and I would tell my group hey
once you accept this charge it's too
late now you have the expectation fans
paid out good money in a high priced
ticket to go to the game they don't care
if you have any issues at home they
don't care if someone is sick in your
family when you accept that Jersey you
line up and it's the kickoff they expect
you to perform at a high level according
to your contract and you got to do it
Steve Smith the NFL Network right here
in the Rich Eisen show speaking of how
coach is act do you think Sean Payton
should have been flagged for coming off
the sidelines like that last night I
mean they're gonna flag because um you
know they got it they got a kind of
quote unquote keep the control of the
game but that was a high level game if
the states were were high so that coach
knowing Sean Payton you got to show your
players hey I'm in it with you too
you know I can't hit anybody but my
enthusiasm I'm gonna have your back when
I think there's a hog wash call I'm
gonna let the referee know I don't care
if I get a penalty but I want you guys
you know I didn't think it was fair for
you guys and I'm gonna ride with my guys
and that's what you want from your coach
you don't want a coach just sitting
there with his mouth open looking like
he disagrees but he doesn't show that
he's gonna disagree he doesn't show the
players that he has their back so you
like that fire you like it I love that
is that a surprise you know what I even
love I even love Sean kind of running
behind the the the referee talking to
him it kind of did the crossover and
then kind of little tripped him a little
bit like hey you know so I saw that too
we were laughing in the greenroom with
Sean did that I was like oh yeah that
was intentional so when it all comes
down to it though Steve did you have a
problem with the choking cymbal - we
were the Fremen that's that
that's Sean now when he gets hot when he
gets into it now
Seana sounded talk now you you I think
that has was
me and Shawn yelling at each other in
the when I was in Carolina yelled at him
a few times on the sidelines I yell down
one time he used to have like he's have
a defense coordinator there and II
yelled us also had a head coach I didn't
really be very fond of Jim has that I
remember one time I was yelling at Jim
Haslett on the sideline I said y'all got
this chump coming me today you suck you
know you're terrible coach and so we got
into it a few times when Jim Haslett was
the head coach so seeing that with with
Sean and Sushant is you know and I don't
mind it because you know that Coach is
going to coach his team to beat you so
you got to bring you a game Thursday
night short week oh my one hear no
excuse you got that judge you go out
there and play Steve Smith here on the
Rich Eisen show and yet Devonta Freeman
almost did choked putting the ball on
the ground as they were trying to run
out the clock before that penalty that
Sean Payton incurred I mean that would
have been a monster turnover to go along
with Matt Ryan's turnovers what would
what do you think about the Falcons
moving focusing now they're in a good
spot eight and five and have their
ability to make the ticket punched for
the playoffs right in their own hands
Steve what do you think about the
Falcons after what you saw last night
well before the game I just said I
expected the Saints to win handily
because of how well round it and how
this how the Saints Drew Brees Sean
Payton offense has evolved where you
don't rely on the drew as much but I
didn't expect the Atlanta to come out
way they did they they did so I had to
eat some humble pie and you know I said
there's a to race to to team race in the
NFC South they put themselves right in
the thick of it and what's even better
is they all play each other still and
week 17 not to skip over but week 17 is
going to be crucial because they play
the Carolina Panthers in Atlanta man
that's gonna be exciting to see what
happens because it it may end up being
the deciding factor if they go to
playoffs
that maybe game 256 on NBC that may be
the last game of the year ask him the
poll question Chris asked Steve Smith
the poll question hey Steve who wins the
NFC South Falcons Panthers Satan what do
you think all said and done well you got
it I you got to go with the team what
they have done collectively you can't
always just go with what they've done
lately and so collectively you have seen
the New Orleans Saints clay well they've
already beat the Carolina Panthers twice
well when I look at the Carolina
Panthers they've been missing some guys
they get their chain mover back Greg
Olson so you would hope he gets back in
a rhythm but you've got to go you know I
went to public school so I'm gonna go go
with the team with the highest number so
I'm going with I'm going with the Saints
but if you have a lander playing the way
they play and you have Carolina sneaked
in and beat possibly the Vikings and
they get momentum well whichever team in
NC Styles gets the best momentum will be
the hot hand and and and that's really
my answer because I know I was supposed
to say something I really don't know
that's the best but that is the best
part about football as analyst right now
I can sit here and say what I think well
you don't know you do not know who's
gonna do what who's gonna who's gonna
wake up and say you know what I'm
Superman today hey Steve by the way
that's the best thing you could say as
part of the paparazzi is and that's part
of our mantra at the NFL Network which
is why you fit in so well it's like look
we think we we we we give an opinion but
we can admit that we don't all know and
that's the way Mayock is with the draft
that's the way you and Marshall and Irv
and everybody is with this league and I
mean it's refreshing but hey look you're
right the Saints do look great and if
chimera comes back they might be the
ones to win it all before I let you go
Steve I would be remiss if I didn't ask
you what you thought about Mike
Mitchell's dramatic soliloquy based on
the fact that juju Smith Shuster got a
game for blowing up vantes perfect on
what used to be a Hines Ward legal hit
what did you think of of all that from
Monday Night Football and what Mike
Mitchell said about putting flags on
players
well um I didn't I I didn't listen to
Mike Mitchell show I'm not sure what he
said no I'm not gonna go back and listen
to it anyway
sure um you know it'd be equivalent to
allowing my three-year-old to tell me
how to fill out a job application yeah
so but I am a huge fan of Jewish man
Schuster and I and I do believe when you
are suspending players based on his and
you're suspending and doing all this
stuff I think realistically there is a
process that doesn't seem to have a real
system it's a it's a moving target and
we need to have it on solid ground
athletes are sometimes machines we are
told when where and how and with the
with the suspensions they don't seem to
have anything concrete isn't it is
always moving and I don't think that's
fair to players when you have a moving
target
it has to be consistent especially if
you're going to get a 20 a 200 million
dollar contract do you want your
contract to be moving so I think you
need to have a a standard in which
everybody knows in fine print I'm with
you Steve thanks for the call as always
travel safe and I look forward to seeing
you as always on Sunday morning with all
of us in the network take care of Steve
you bet that's the man at 89 Steve Smith
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience